okay so in this module we would like to
talk about first order logic so far
we've been talking about propositional
logic you've talked about the syntax of
propositional logic it's semantics and
we've also talked about a few different
inference rules so we've talked about
modus ponens and and resolution okay
and now we want to extend our logic and
make it a little bit fancier make it a
little bit more complicated and and
think about first order logic so the
first question to ask is why do we even
want to do that why is why is
propositional logic not enough like if
you remember we talked about resolution
and and resolution was was taking an
exponential amount of time to to to be
solved and it seemed pretty powerful
right like if you can if you can do that
in propositional logic it seems pretty
useful it seems pretty powerful so so
what are some of the limitations of
prepositional logic okay so so let me
show that in one example so imagine we
start with a sentence that says alice
and bob both know are athletic so if i
want to write this in propositional
logic one way of doing that is is that i
can have a set of set of symbols for
positional symbols one being alice knows
arithmetic and i can have another
prepositional symbol about bob knows
arithmetic and this can take true or
false values and one way of writing this
is is by writing this this
this particular formula where i can
write alice knows arithmetic and bob
knows everything okay
so this seems uh something this seems a
little weird right right this seems like
something is wrong here so what is wrong
here
so if i try to extend this and and write
something that's slightly more
complicated
this type of writing symbols and adding
them and so on just doesn't scale it's
not expressive enough let's say i write
all students know earth if i'm writing
all students no arithmetic
then i'm going to list all student names
and then have a single
a single prepositional symbol for each
of students knowing arithmetic and
ending that and that just just doesn't
scale if i have a lot of students if
you're in a class like 221 that wouldn't
really scale right like i need to write
alice's student implies alice knows
arithmetic bob the student implies bob
knows arithmetic and each one of these
is going to be a symbol that takes like
true false by itself and and this is
going to go up fairly quickly even worse
like i can have a situation where i i
write a preposition that says
i i write a statement that says every
even integer greater than two is the sum
of two primes okay so this is actually a
gold box conjecture okay so if i want to
write this in logic well i'm kind of
screwed right like i can't write this in
propositional logic because it's talking
about every even integer and there's an
infinite number of them so i'm not going
to be able to write that in
propositional logic okay so so what can
we do it it looks like if i'm using
propositional logic it's very clunky and
then there is there is kind of like a
lot of proposition a lot of
prepositional symbols going on and it
just wouldn't scale
but if you think about it like when
you're thinking about these statements
there are some objects here and then
some relationships some predicates
between these objects and maybe we can
use that structure there's quite a bit
of structure here right like alice being
a student or robbing a student right
like being a student is is a predicate
on top of this object object being alice
or object being bob so maybe we can use
that structure and instead of defining a
single propositional symbol for
everything maybe we can talk about
objects and predicates instead okay so
so what that means is here for example
like in this other example alice knowing
you're arithmetic alice you can think of
it as an object arithmetic you can think
of it as an object and knowing is a
predicate on top of alice and arithmetic
and maybe we can we can think about that
structure and in general this other view
that there are some objects and some
predicates on top of them and think of
that as a way of writing a new type of
logic in addition to that like for that
example
i was talking about every integer having
a property then for for those types of
types of specifications we need to think
about quantifiers right we need to think
about ways of saying for all or rays of
saying there exists so so we need to
have a way of representing these
quantifiers and to represent the
quantifier we need to have a variable
right so when i say for all students
right i need to have a variable x that
corresponds to every single student so
in addition to these objects and
predicates we need to have quantifiers
and variables and then we need to use
quantifiers and variables to represent
to represent our our statements here
okay let me let me give you
an example so so what i want to do in
this in this module today is i want to
talk about the syntax of first order
logic and i want to then talk about
semantics of first order logic and the
next module i'll be talking about and
friends rules but i'm not gonna go into
as much like i'm not gonna do justice
here so i'm not gonna
go into as much details and syntax and
semantics the same way that we did in
propositional logic so it's a little bit
more high level here okay so let me just
give you a couple of examples here so so
if i'm saying alice and bob both know
arithmetic in first order logic ideally
i would want to be able to write
something of this form like something
that says hey predicate of knowing
over alice and arithmetic over over
these these objects alice and arithmetic
should be true and the same predicate of
knowing over bob and arithmetic again
arithmetic is the same symbol should be
true okay so i want to be able to
capture that structure of objects and
predicates in first order watching
the other thing is like going back to
this other student all students knowing
arithmetic i should be able to have
quantifiers and variables so so ideally
if i want to write this in first order
logic i would i should write something
of this form for all x
x being a student predicate of student
over variable of x should imply x
knowing arithmetic again knowing is the
same predicate as before okay
so these are actually just examples of
first order logic but but how do we do
this how do we get to these get to these
statements for that we need to define
the syntax of first order logic so so
let's get into the syntax of first order
logic
all right
so let me go to my notebook so so we're
going to talk about first order logic
and it's syntax
and when you're defining a syntax of
first order logic we have two types of
things going on we have terms
and we have formulas
if you remember prepositional logic we
only had formulas here here we first
need to define a set of terms and these
terms are expressions that are referring
to objects okay so so they are
expressions
that are referring to objects
okay
okay so what are terms so the first
thing that we consider as term is a
constant symbol
okay
so alice for example or math
or arithmetic or whatever these are
constant symbols okay so constant symbol
is is a term in addition to constant
symbols we need to have variables like
as i as i was talking about earlier if
you want to if you want to be able to
talk about quantifiers those quantifiers
need to be defined over variables so so
a variable is kind of like if when i say
for all x x does something that x is a
variable okay
and in addition to that we we can have
functions here and these functions are
defined on some of these terms so so
functions can be defined on terms and
and they also give us terms so for
example i can look at a function like
summing over x and 3. so if i'm looking
at sum of
3 and x x is a variable 3 here is a
constant symbol summing over that is a
function and that also gives me a chance
okay
all right so so that is uh that is terms
so now i can talk about formulas okay so
so now that i've defined terms i can
talk about formulas the the most basic
form of a formula
is is an atomic formula this is actually
very similar to our prepositional
symbols in propositional logic so so
this is kind of like the basis of it
right in propositional logic we had
these propositional symbols like p or
negation of negation of p we would
define negation on top of that but p was
this this propositional symbol here
atomic formula is kind of like the basis
of of this of this logic okay so so what
is an atomic formula an atomic formula
is a predicate applied to terms okay so
so for example bob knowing arithmetic is
is an atomic formula i can write that as
um
nose
nose is a predicate applied to symbol
constant symbol bob and constant symbol
arithmetic
okay and
this whole thing is an atomic formula
okay so once we have the atomic formula
then what we can do is we can do
operations on top of these right we
could we could do the same things that
we did in propositional logic we can
have logical connectives on top of them
connectives
on top of these so uh apply to these
formulas so these logical connectives
are things like negation or or
and or implication
bi-directional implication we can just
apply the same sort of things similar to
propositional logic here and in addition
to that we are going to define
quantifiers so quantifiers is going to
be defined on top of all of these and
these quantifiers are things like for
all or there exists okay
all right
so this defines the syntax of our first
order logic we have terms we have
formulas and then formulas atomic
formulas are basically going to be
predicates on top of terms and once we
have the atomic formulas we can play
around with them using the connectives
logical connectives or using the
quantifiers
let's go back here so a quick recap of
that constant symbols like arithmetic
variables just like x functions like sum
of three and x and then we have formulas
it's referring to kind of like these
truth values uh and and atomic formulas
are predicates applied to terms
connectives connect them for example you
might say uh x is a student implies x
knows arithmetic so this implication is
connecting this predicate on top of
symbol on top of the variable to this
predicate on top of the variable and the
symbol
and then in addition to that once we
have variables we can have quantifiers
you can say for all x if x is student
that implies x knows everything okay
all right so that summarizes the syntax
of first order logic
one quick note on quantifiers is if you
think about quantifiers quantifiers are
are just slightly more complicated
versions of ants and ores so if you
think about the for all quantifier the
universal quantification you can think
of it literally as a conjunction okay so
when i say for all x p of x that's very
similar to saying p of a and p of b and
p of c and so on okay and and and this
for all is kind of like being treated as
ants between all the possible things
that can attack that
that this x can take okay
similarly if you talk about existential
quantification there exists that is kind
of like an or you can think of it as a
disjunction if i say there exists xp of
x it's very similar to saying p of a or
pfp or pfc and so on
and if i have a finite number of them
then i can actually enumerate all of
that i can actually unroll this and
enumerate all of them okay
um okay so then if for all and there
exists are kind of like and and or then
i can apply the morgan's law so what
that means is if i have a negation
outside of one of these quantifiers if i
say negation of for all x p x that is
equivalent to saying there exists x
negation of px
why because the the ands are going to be
flipped to become ors so so for all
becomes there exists and the negation
becomes inside just like the morgan's
law applies to enzymes
all right
another point i want to make here is is
if when we say for all x there exists y
we can't flip the order again just like
hand and earth you can't really like
flip this order right if i say for all x
there exists y so then x knows y that's
pretty different from saying there
exists y such that for all x x knows y
so so we can't like simply flip their
orders do not do that
okay so so now that we know the syntax
of first order logic let's talk about
how we can start from natural language
and from natural language how can we
write first order logic so if you think
about universal quantification when we
talk about for all the way that we
usually refer to that in natural
language is by using the word like every
okay so if i say every student knows
arithmetic i would use the for all like
quantifier right like i'm saying for all
x because that corresponds to every
student
so
is this the right so it's a question to
ask is is this the right way of writing
this natural language statement i have
every student knows arithmetic
i would write for all x
student x is student
okay
and then in addition to that i write x
knows arithmetic
but this doesn't actually correspond to
this sentence so there is there is
something a little bit subtle going on
here then you say every student knows
arithmetic
basically if you're conditioning it like
knowing you're arithmetic on being a
student
but the statement here is not doing that
conditioning this statement is is
basically saying everyone is student and
everyone knows arithmetic and then
that's not right right not everyone
knows arithmetic every student knows
arithmetic so because there is that
conditioning that goes on and in our
like in this statement and it's kind of
like implied in this natural language
the correct way of writing this is by
using an implication so if i want to
write out the statement every student
knows arithmetic i would write for all x
of x as a student then that implies that
x knows arithmetic okay so condition on
that person being a student then x knows
everything and then that that is an
implication
we're going to have a couple of these
examples and and what i'm in the
assignment the logic assignment so so i
think it's kind of like a good rule of
rule of thumb to to think about
for all employees every time you see
every so so this is not always true but
in in general if you if you see like
every every student or every person does
whatever it's it's usually of the form
of for all implications okay
how about there exists so so let's say
that we have some student knows
arithmetic so when we talk about some
student then we have to use existential
quantifier and the actual correct way of
writing this is to say well there exists
some student and an x knows arithmetic
so so an and is going to be sufficient
here so every time you see a sum it it's
usually corresponding to there exists
and an and and every time you see every
it's usually corresponding to for all
and an implication
all right
so note that there are different
connectives here for for for all and
there exists usually when you start from
natural language
okay let's look at a few examples let's
see examples let's see if we can write
these in first order logic so first
example is there is some course that
every student has taken
okay how do we write this
so there is some course so so so
there
exists a y such that y is a course okay
there is some course this is this is to
that part of it there is some course
there is a y so y is a course
that every student has taken it so
that's the and part and there is
something true about this course what is
true about this course every student has
taken it
so how do we write every student has
taken it what that says is for all x
when x is a student that implies that x
that student has taken the course y
okay all right so that's the first
example
let's look at the second example so
every if you've seen this example
earlier uh in this module so every even
integer greater than 2 is the sum of is
the sum of two primes how do we write
this so it says every even integer so if
it says every if i see every then i
would expect to see it for all x and
some implication that comes later so so
what is that x for all x that x is an
even integer and this is greater than
two so so for every even integer greater
than two so even integer greater than
two
what do i get for that even integer
greater than two that implies that
that that integer is going to be the sum
of two primes so so how do i write that
i'm going to use there exists y and
there exists c to correspond to those
two primes right so that integer is
going to be sum of two primes there
exists a prime and there exists another
prime there exists a y and there is
another z so so that i i i can say
sum
and y is a prime and z is a prime and
sum of y and z is equal to x that
integer
okay
all
right let's look at another example if a
student takes a course and the course
covers a concept then the student knows
the concept
so if it's kind of like every remember
like every was also kind of like if
right like when we're seeing every we
would say for all implies if it's kind
of the same thing if it's basically
saying hey if a student basically means
for every student so so if a student
takes the course and the course covers
the concept then the student knows the
concept so for all x
x being a student okay
and
x takes a course y so for all course y
and for all concepts c so so these four
alls are for all student and for all
course and for all concept if x is a
student and x takes y and y is a course
and y covers z if you want it to be like
pedantic and right we should have had
and z is a concept but i'm skipping that
then what does that tell me
then the student knows the concept right
the thing that comes after a comma is
the thing that comes after after this
implication right then the student x
knows the concept c
okay all right so that was going from
natural language to first order logic
and and we're able to talk about the
syntax of first order logic using terms
and then using using these formulas
defined over terms so so now let's talk
about the semantics of first order logic
how do we define the meaning or
semantics for this first order logic so
if you remember the semantics how we
define semantics for propositional logic
they defined it by this using this idea
of models right like models representing
a particular situation in the world okay
so in propositional logic and model w
was a world
that was mapping prepositional symbols
to truth values it was it was a truth
assignment to propositional symbols so
if going back to my original example
alice knows arithmetic and bob knows
arithmetic if i were to write that in in
propositional logic i would basically
have these propositional symbols alice
knows arithmetic bob knows arithmetic
and a model would assign one or zero to
each one of these prepositional symbols
that was in prepositional watching
how do we think about it in first order
logic
so the reason we think about this in
first order logic is by having a graph
representation for every model so so you
can think about predicates that we have
been talking about like knowing
arithmetic and so on as either like
unary or binary predicates that are
defined over over these terms that we
are talking about okay so so a model w
can basically be represented by by a
graph here so so so a w could be a graph
where we have these these different
nodes and each node corresponds to an
object okay so so an object is going to
be represented uh by a node and then
we're labeling each node by constant
symbol okay so node one o1 is an object
and it's going to be labeled by alice
and node two might be an object and it's
corresponded to like both bob and robert
and o3 is corresponding to uh is a note
to corresponding to an object
corresponding to an arithmetic then what
we can do is we can have directed edges
here that that basically talk about
binary predicates so alice knowing
arithmetic corresponds to this directed
edge that corresponds to this predicate
knows apply to alice and alice and
arithmetic and for for unary predicates
we're basically joining just going to
have the predicate on top of the note so
alice being a student okay
all right so that defines a model here
so so a model in the first order logic
basically has two components one is that
it basically has constant symbols
assigned to two objects so so so
basically a model for for alice
corresponds to node 01 and
bob corresponds to node o2 and
arithmetic corresponds to node 03 and
then we have predicate symbols that's
that are basically giving us these two
poles of oh one no angle three or o two
knowing o3 so so that corresponds to w
of knowing that predicate of knowing
which basically gives us these two poles
either either they could be binary or
unary depending on depending on their
predicate
all right so the way we are defining a
model is a little bit more complex than
the way we defined modeled in
propositional logic
so so there are a few other restrictions
that we are putting on models to make
our lives a little bit easier so so if
you remember um okay so we can have um
basically a statement that says john and
bob are students right so how do i write
this and and first order logic i can say
john a student and and all the students
so students predicate on top of john and
bob
so if i think about a model
corresponding to that i can have a note
01 corresponding to john and and student
predicate student on top of this node
and i can have node o2 responding to bob
and student on top of this
but that's one option right one could
have other types of models that
represent this i can have a single note
and i can say well this person's name is
both john and bob maybe john and bob
are the same people and and uh we're
talking about uh both of them being a
student so one other option is w2 one
other way of representing this model is
w2 where i just write one note or maybe
i have three notes maybe i have like
this other unnamed note here that that
doesn't have anyone assigned to it so
the restriction that we are putting in
here is basically trying to make sure
that w2 and w3 doesn't happen so so
basically we are putting this unique
names assumption which says each object
has at most one constant symbol for it
and this basically rules out w and in
addition to the w
sorry this rules that w two basically we
can't have both john and bob associated
to the single node to the single object
so we can have at most one constant
symbol
and in addition to that you're going to
have another assumption on domain
closure which basically says each object
has at least one constant symbol so so
we can't have an object corresponding to
o2 here that doesn't have any symbols
assigned to it so this rules out double
e3 so this basically ensures that when
when we have a constant symbol a
constant symbol is equivalent to having
an object if i have an object there is
one single constant
constant symbol that is assigned to it
okay
so why am i trying to do this like what
would this buy me so the thing that
despised me this one to one mapping that
we have between constant symbols and
objects like using using these two
assumptions that i've put allows me to
do to do an operation that called
prepositionalization
and and what that buys me is actually it
advised me to to be able to use
inference rules that were in
propositional logic the whole reason i'm
doing this is so i can i can use ideas
from propositional logic like resolution
or modus ponens when it comes to
inference um in first order logic okay
so if you think about it if we make this
restriction then first order logic is
not anything fancy right it's just
syntactic trigger on top of
propositional logic it it helps us write
things a little bit more expressively
and have like an easier time like
writing out things but at the end of the
day it's it's kind of like the same
thing the same sort of logic that goes
behind everything okay so uh for example
if we have like this this example
knowledge base in first order logic we
might say alice's student and bob is
student and every student is a person so
for all x axis student that implies x is
a person and some students are creative
so for for their existing x or x as a
student and x is created x is creative
okay so this is my knowledge base in
first order logic okay one can write
this exact knowledge base in
propositional logic right like i can
actually do that now based on this
assumption that that every constant
symbol has a one-to-one mapping to an
object i can simply write this in
prepositional logic i can say student
alice i can say student pop both of
these are our prepositional symbols i
can have an and of them and then student
alice implies personalis which is
another another propositional symbol and
student bob employs person bob
student alice and creative alice or
student bob and creative bob is what i
get from this last next question